♪ ♪
>> Kimberly: WELCOME BACK.
I AM VERY UPSET.
TWO OF MY FAVORITE THINGS,
SANDWICHES AND MEAT, THEY ARE
COMING UNDER ATTACK.
CLAIMING HAMBURGERS, STEAKS AND
YOU KNOW THEM.
KINDS OF REASONS BECAUSE OF
INGREDIENTS AND PACKAGING.
DANA, CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS
RIDICULOUS --
>> Dana: I SAW THERE IS GOING
TO BE MANDATORY ROOF GARDENS IN
DENVER.
YOU SHOULD GO TO WATTERS' WORLD
OUT THERE.
MANDATORY ROOF GARDENS IN
DENVER.
>> Kimberly: GREENING.
OUT OF THE DONALD TRUMP PLAYBOOK
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
MAKE THE ART OF THE DEAL.
THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES, SPRINT TOOK A
SURPRISING NUMBER THAT SUPPORT
THE IDEA OF A CARBON TAX.
IF THEY WERE TO DO THAT, THESE
OTHER THINGS THEY WANT TO DO
PEOPLE TO EAT WOULD GO AWAY.
>> Kimberly: GREG, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS?
YOU ARE A CARNIVORE.
GIVING AWAY AT STRAWS AT
RESTAURANTS, YOU CAN GO TO JAIL.
YOU DON'T EVEN READ THE STUFF I
>> Greg: NEVER MIND.
>> Kimberly: WHAT IS WRONG
WITH YOU?
>> Greg: LET'S TALK ABOUT
EVOLUTIONARY SCIENCE.
MEAT AND MADE US THE KING OF ALL
BEASTS BECAUSE THERE'S NO OTHER
WAY TO GET PROTEIN RICH
NUTRIENTS AND MEAT.
YOU CAN SAY EAT SPINACH.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO RENT A
U-HAUL TO EAT ALL THE SPINACH
YOU GET FROM A STATE.
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE THESE
BRAINS IS BECAUSE WE ATE SO MUCH
MEAT FOR 200,000 YEARS.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND VEGANISM,
THEY ARE ALL ABLE TO EXIST IN
2018 BECAUSE OF THE MEAT EATERS
OF THE PAST WHO BUILT THIS
FRINGE CAUSES.
>> Kimberly: OKAY, I DON'T GET
THIS.
IT IS SO CRAZY, JESSE.
THEY ARE SAYING IT CAUSES GLOBAL
WARMING, ALL OF IT.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO ME.
WHAT ABOUT THE CHILDREN, JESSE?
EAT SANDWICHES.
>> Jesse: DO IT FOR THE KIDS.
DON'T TOUCH THE LUNCHABLES.
AMERICANS WON'T TOLERATE
ENVIRONMENTAL WACKOS -- THEY SAY
WE HAVE TO RECYCLE, NOT THE
AEROSOL CANS.
WE SAY OKAY.
THEN THEY COME AFTER THE MEAT
AND NO.
WE ARE DRAWING THE HEADLINE
HAMBURGERS AND HOTDOGS.
THEY ALREADY TALKED ABOUT WE
CAN'T DRIVE CERTAIN CARS.
THEY HAVE SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
SODAS.
THEY WON'T LET US DRINK SODAS.
IT'S GOT TO THE POINT WHERE IT'S
BECOME RIDICULOUS AND THEY
ARE --
KERRY I HAD TWO HOTDOGS TODAY.
NO BOND.
>> Jesse: NO BOND?
>> Kimberly: I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
BONDS.
THERE WAS NOTHING.
I USE A LITTLE SPICY MUSTARD.
I HAD PEPPERONI TODAY TOO.
>> Greg: YOU ARE GOING TO BE
DOING THIS IN TEN YEARS WHEN YOU
ARE MY AGE.
NO MORE BREAD.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE EATING
NOTHING BUT MEAT.
>> Jesse: WHAT'S WRONG WITH
BRAD?
>> Greg: CARBOHYDRATES, SUGAR
MAKES YOU FAT.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT SO SURE
ABOUT THAT.
>> Kimberly: WHAT KIND OF DIET
ARE YOU ON NOW?
WHAT HAPPENED OVER THE HOLIDAYS?
JUAN, WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT THIS?
>> Juan: LET ME SAY WHAT IS
SURPRISING IS THEY TAKE THE
WORST SANDWICH, THE ONE THAT HAS
THE WORST, MOST IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT, BREAKFAST SANDWICH
WITH SAUSAGE, BACON, EGGS.
THEY SAID IT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF
DRIVING 12 MILES IF YOU JUST EAT
ONE.
>> Jesse: I DROVE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY THIS MORNING.
I HAD TWO BACON EGG AND CHEESE
SANDWICHES.
CHEESE OVER SAUSAGE?
>> Jesse: I WOULD GO FOR THE
BACON.
>> Juan: WORSE THAN YOUR
PRIVATE PLANE IN TERMS OF --
>> Greg: IF YOU PUT BREAD ON
THE SANDWICHES, WHAT YOU'RE
YOGURT.
A BIG DISH OF YOGURT FROM
WHEREVER IT IS LIKE HAVING
ICE CREAM FOR BREAKFAST.
IF YOU HAVE LEAN MEAT, PROTEIN,
AND EGG, THE YOLK, NOT THE
WHITES.
ENOUGH OF THIS EGG WHITE CRAP.
>> Kimberly: I AM WITH YOU.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> Dana: YOU CAN GET THIS
NOWHERE ELSE ON CABLE NEWS.
>> Kimberly: I HAD A
HARD-BOILED EGG TOO.
>> Juan: TAKE IT EASY.
I WAS STUNNED TO REALIZE IT'S AS